[Music]
it is time for those summer celebrations
weddings family reunions fourth of july
maybe you're getting ready to put your
home on the market
anytime is a great time to experience
clean carpet and if you're tired of
living with spots and dirty traffic
lanes and pet issues
it's zero rez to the rescue the number
one most referred and recommended carpet
cleaner in las vegas and i'm joined by
ben mckee
the general manager of xero res las
vegas
ben we often hear about the zero res
difference can you tell us what is the
zero res difference
well the first thing is we don't use any
any
soaps or harsh chemicals in our cleaning
it's strictly just our powered water
technology
and that enables us to clean our carpets
and leave behind
zero dirt attracting residue and we
don't want to use those harmful
chemicals and those
soaps because don't they end up making
your carpet
dirtier than it already was
it does so it its job is to attract dirt
so it stays in the carpet
and it keeps doing its job and that's
why your spots come back
and your carpets dry crunchy it's just
gross you do not want
soap in your carpets now the dog days of
summer
are here and we all know what that means
the number one problems that homeowners
face are pet
stains xero rez though you guys are the
pet treatment experts tell us about the
process and how you
can rescue this carpet that our pets
destroy well we all love our fur babies
and so we can go back to lebanon if you
call zero reds we've got
safe non-toxic products that actually
remove the cause of the stain
and the odor so your carpets and floors
can go back to looking fresh
and smelling fresh as well now whenever
homeowners they
look for home service companies the
first thing they do is they check out
the reviews to get recommendations and i
looked at your reviews no one comes
close to you guys in that department why
do you think
xerorez is rated number one with las
vegas homeowners
well the the big thing is you know we
always tout our technology that we have
but our big secret is our it's just our
technicians or it's our employees
they're properly trained they're
background checked and the best part is
we
train strictly on providing the best
customer experience possible
that's why we've got 5600 google reviews
here in las vegas
i think i might be one of them honestly
we know that you guys have
a special for us today and tell us who
you're teaming up with for this great
special
oh yeah we're teaming up with cowabunga
bay it's been hot and we did it so
get your carpets cleaned and go for a
swim at kalabunga bay
yeah that would be really nice while
they're cleaning your carpets at home
get out and enjoy
enjoy it in las vegas number one water
park
thank you so much ben we just love
zerorez and we have a great special for
you we definitely want you to take
advantage
of the kickoff summer special so you can
get three rooms of carpet cleaned for
only
99 plus you're gonna get two free passes
to cowabunga bay
just call them at 702-840-3333
or go to zerorezlas vegas.com minimum
supply
las vegas now we'll be right back